of all the places that are suffering in
haiti today this may be one of the
deepest wells of misery port-au-prince's
general hospital where patients receive
bare bones treatment for chronic
diseases covet infections and traumatic
injuries this man says he was attacked
by bandits with machetes
they tried to kill me and i don't even
know who it was
compounding conditions in haitian
healthcare a severe fuel shortage is
crippling many hospitals the public
electrical grid is unreliable so
hospitals are powered by generators
without fuel for the generators
hospitals can't operate kidney dialysis
machines ventilators incubators for
premature babies and other equipment
when the hospital cannot provide
properly because of the fuel problem
that affects other things so
they can provide the right services for
the kids pregnant women and covet
patients
many hospitals are now near the end of
their supplies some 40 hospitals have
sent a message to unicef saying that
they may have to close immediately is
this is this true what's the situation
there we situational effects will
hospitals close
there are a lot of hospitals that will
close because they can't find fuel so
they can't function
the majority of them are public and
private
the fuel crisis is largely due to gangs
that have hijacked tanker trucks and
blockaded the port where fuel depots are
located
dozens of hospitals have warned that
they may have to shut their doors in the
coming days as a result of the fuel
shortage and that would leave thousands
of people in need of medical care with
no place to go milan bienneme has come
to the hospital bringing food and
clothing for her 20 year old nephew who
is suffering from severe diabetes
you have to buy everything for them
my nephew is a diabetic so he needs
medication but everything is shut down
u.n agencies and haitian authorities are
trying to create a sort of humanitarian
corridor to get fuel to hospitals but
unless there is a breakthrough the
consequences may be dire message
situation
if the situation continues the day will
come
this weekend coming up with hundreds of
complications and deaths
in a country full of suffering with a
government that has virtually ceased to
function the prospects for these
patients and many other haitians is
bleak
rob reynolds al jazeera port-au-prince